so hello there that was hot I'm your
interim host Cal small this is another
episode of biographics and today we're
talking about King George V 6 The
Reluctant Monarch and as with all the
videos here on biographics this one is
based on original script submitted To Us
by a member of our writing team member
of that writing team today being Larry
holsworth who you can follow on their
social media links found below while
you're down there why don't you leave a
like a comment with feedback or
suggestions for future videos and
subscribe for more content like this
normally I would ask this at the end of
the video but the Analytics the people
behind the scenes have told me the
earlier you say this the more likely all
three things are to happen so can you
say them early in the video please so
yeah there you go Eric Jen everybody
else behind the scenes did I do good
let's get to
it much of the life of Albert Frederick
Arthur George called berti by family and
friends and by me throughout the rest of
his video because it's very funny can be
summed up in one word unexpected at the
time of his birth his father held the
title The Duke of York later to ascend
to the throne of the United Kingdom in
Great Britain as King George V berty was
his second son and thus was not expected
to ascend to the throne himself The Heir
Apparent under George V was bertie's
brother who became king Edward VII in
1936 thus it was his brother who was
groomed as the man who would be king
berti was prepared for other duties
expected of the royal family in the
first half of the 20th century I.E not
very much Bertie was born on December
14th 189 5 the second eventually five
Sons as a child his health was shall we
say not strong his natural inclination
was to use his left as his dominant hand
a quirk not tolerated by his family and
tutors he was frequently ill and
developed a stutter as a child another
trait which his family considered to be
intolerable forced to right with his
right hand ashamed of his stutter and
prone to tears when frightened which was
often as he was terrified of loud noises
and large animals Bertie became shy and
withdrawn leg braces intended to correct
his knock knees and added to his
childhood troubles and is anybody else
getting like major Forest Gump vibes
from this of just like you know when
Forest Gump's little and he's got lot
little leg braces on he's like oh man
you feel so bad for that kid so he start
running real fast like yeah you go for a
SK though he saw his parents twice a day
when they were in Residence they had
little to do with rearing their children
those duties were instead performed by
the pleps the nannies the tutors and
other servants in the employee of the
Royal
Family 1909 in accordance with family
tradition Bertie entered the Royal Navy
as a Cadet of the royal Naval Academy in
Osborne on the Isle of white he
struggled there as well finishing last
in his class in 1911 before moving on to
the Royal Navy College in Dartmouth by
then he was the son of the king his
father having ascended to the throne in
1910 Naval Cadets trained both in the
classroom and out at Sea where Bertie
quickly demonstrated a tendency toward
seasickness a unfortunate and career
killing malady for one considering a
naval career Bertie never fully overcame
his seasickness and his health continued
to be problematic for example he dealt
with ulcers and in the early months of
World War I with appendicitis I've been
there wait your appendix is this side
but mine aren't cuz mine are gone
despite his problems which persisted
along with his stutter Bertie continued
to serve and was aboard the HMS
Collingwood during the Battle of Jutland
in 1916 his Service as a t officer was
sufficient for him to be mentioned in
dispatches an award for gallantry during
in the battle such a performance was
certainly shall we say unexpected given
his persistent ill health his poor
performance in training and his nervous
Nature by 1917 he was a short recovering
from surgery for his ulcers and he later
returned to service with the Royal Navy
Flying Service Learning to Fly himself
displaying far more aptitude for being
in the air than he did on the water he
transferred from the Royal Navy into the
newly formed Royal Air Force later that
same year despite his poor health ber
somewhat unexpectedly excelled at sports
particularly tennis he played well
enough to actually enter the men's
doubles at Wimbledon in 1926 though he
and his partner Lis Greek were
eliminated in the first round and God
Dam imagine like just scoring an ace on
the Future King of England like I would
never not tell that story at every
family gathering until the day I died by
then he had completed courses in
economics and history at the Trinity
College and frequently represented the
royal family in official appearances
still he appeared less confident in
public than his brother Edward the
Prince of Wales he appeared as Albert
Prince of York in His official capacity
hampered by his stutter he spoke
infrequently in public which attributed
further to his image of being reserved
shy and
timid ah oh look it's business antier
what are we talking about today business
antier nordvpn okay let's go we we live
in a very connected world there's
probably people out there right now
watching this on their toilet on like
you know their neighbor's Wi-Fi and
that's great good for you but it pays to
be careful with your data and you might
not think well I'm just watching a
YouTube video on my phone like how how
much data can someone really get from
that the answer is quite a lot so it
pays to look after yourself if you
connect to a Wi-Fi service you think is
safe for example if you're at a cafe and
it just says insert brand here Wi-Fi yes
for all you know that might not be the
Wi-Fi for that business that might be
some kind of scammer trying to get your
information and yeah and this is one
thing it's a lot more common than you're
thinking it even has a name and it's not
the man in the mirror attack so I was
going to make a Michael Jackson joke and
I never know it's called man in the
middle which makes my joke not make
sense so and just think about how often
it is you'll go into a bar a cafe um a
museum an airport and just connect to
the first like strongest connection free
Wi-Fi that you can see and how often do
you actually query whether or not that's
legit so this is why novpn is a good
service it's because one of the things
that they'll do is encrypt the data that
you are transmitting from your device no
matter where that data goes so you could
connect to this other person's Wi-Fi but
they still wouldn't be able to get
anything from you you might think what
what why would I care it's like we've
all got stuff on our phone that we've
searched for that we don't want anybody
else knowing about let's be honest here
another good thing about nordvpn as well
is you just need one account to cover
all the household devices yes up to six
I believe and I am like an extreme Edge
case here and I have
one
two uh three four five and then six in
the other so I've got six devices just
for me as one person I'm an extreme Edge
case and I would still be protected n
VPN also has a threat protection feature
which protects you from ads trackers and
malware so yeah if you are like looking
up any weird sites Carl for work it does
prevent you from visiting malicious
sites and uh scans any files that you
download as well yeah I Do download a
lot of files for work I do yes thank you
to today's sponsor nordvpn check out
nordvpn and get 4 months extra ra on a
2-year plan by going to nordvpn.com
bio it's risk-free with nordvpn's 30-day
money back guarantee and guys the thing
we've been doing with our sponsor spots
recently is ending them with an extra
bonus fact you'll find nowhere else in
the video so would you like the bonus
pack for today yay okay did you know
that zoos around the world keep
accidentally trying to make gay sloths
so like you know many animals display
something known as sexual dimorphism
essentially just the difference between
a male and female of the species sloes
don't really have any of that to the
point where experts on them can't really
tell the difference between a male and a
female and I know what you're thinking
like Brad Anisha surely they can just
like you know just pop that tail up and
just see what's hanging between their
legs well male slopes have what is
described as incredibly small genitalia
so small in fact they are almost
impossible to see so this coupled with
like the fact that male and female
examples of the species look virtually
ident icle means that zoos across the
world have frequently tried to get
breeding pairs of slopes that are either
male male or female female and then got
really annoyed when they don't breed
isn't that
fun during the Edwardian era members of
all Europe's Royal houses were expected
to intermar in part because he was not
expected to ascend to the throne his
brother being The Heir Apparent ber he
was given shall we say considerable
leeway when it came to his choice of
Bride in 1920 Bertie began courting
Elizabeth Bow's lion the daughter of the
ear of Strathmore and the wife of
Cecilia Countess of Strathmore berti
proposed marriage Twice first in 1921
and then in 1922 both times his intended
refused him dissuaded by her own mother
who warned Elizabeth of the duties of
the royal family reminding the duties of
the royal family are just standing there
and doing
this actually know if you're the queen
think's this that's the Royal wave isn't
it in 1923 the persistent bir then the
Duke of York won her hand and they were
married later that same year the fact
that he had married someone not of royal
family was noted in the press in a
welcoming manner for the most part it
was considered to be a step forward in
the terms of modernization of the royal
family and its image the couple spent a
full 16 months touring his Majesty's
dominions in Africa during which they
went on Safari searching for bid game
their marriage was by all accounts a
fairly happy one and produced two
daughters Elizabeth nicknamed lilb butth
was born in 1926 and their second
daughter Margaret was born in 1930
unlike the events of his own childhood
Bertie remained close to his children
involved himself in their daily lives
though they could have used one of
several different Royal palaces and
homes as their main residence they
instead chose to reside in London at 145
Picadilly a five-story house in Green
Park it remained their home until berti
ascended to the throne though he
sometimes resided at the Royal Lodge
after
1932 Bertie found the requirements of
his role as a member of the royal family
and he stutter incompatible during the
the 1920s his speaking engagements
became agonizing for him and
embarrassing for those forced to endorse
sitting through them after his return to
Britain in 1925 bery engaged the
services of One linal log a self-taught
elocutionist and speech therapist who
had been for the most part dismissed as
a fraud by the mainstream medical
community speech therapy at the time had
not been considered discipline log
diagnosed the Duke's problems as being
one of poor coordination between his
diaphragm and larynx which could be
corrected through breathing exercises
the exact exercises prescribed by log
for the future King are unknown the Duke
and Mentor did work together on his
problem each day for about an hour and
bery continued to exercise on his own
prior to speaking to anyone gradually he
learned to release the tensions which
led to his stutter and speak slowly and
clearly his progress was quite rapid and
by 1927 he was able to address the
parliament of Australia delivering
prepared remarks smoothly without
stuttering once despite his success
Bertie continued to work with log for
many years in 1952 after George the 6
sudden death his widow wrote to log I
think that I know perhaps better than
anyone just how much you help the king
not only with his speech but throughout
his whole life and outlook on life
itself and just because I knew people
would be curious because I myself was
curious I did some independent research
on this while familiarized myself with
the scripts and could not find any
evidence one way or the other whether or
not that moment in The King's Speech
where log advises the king to swear a
lot is accurate there are some sources
saying that it is where there's some
that deny it because swearing a bunch is
not really something becoming of a king
and if people aren't familiar with what
I'm talking about in the film The King
speech where 30 the subject of today's
video is played by Colin fur there is a
moment in the film where his
elocutionist notes that well when you
swear you you don't stutter you should
swear more and they have this great just
one minute long scene of Colin fur just
being like bugger bugger buger
bugger and it's great and it's fantastic
unfortunately I could find no evidence
of that actually taking place there was
a couple of people like close to the
film who said they think that it does
but they couldn't site any sources out
of fear of like you know like ndas and
just not want to upset at the Royal
Family although I did find a few
articles talking about the fact that
swearing can be a useful verbal crutch
for people who struggle with stuttering
and the like the idea being that because
swearing comes so naturally to you um it
allows you to just you know think of the
next word so that your speech flows more
freely and a proponent of this Theory
and an example of it working is the
actor Samuel L Jackson Who reportedly
suffered from a terrible stutter early
in his childhood and was able to
overcome it um via judicious use of the
word check out the big
brain on
bread you're a smart mother another
actor who suffered with a terrible
stutter was the actor James O Jones who
was reportedly functionally mute for
most of his childhood until he hit
puberty and just you know that voice
came out of his mouth and then he was
able to be more confident in his speech
and I myself um suffer for a m stutter
as a child and something people may
notice um as I go through these videos
is I have a very peculiar way of
speaking you've probably heard heard it
just that I have a almost sing songy
like rising and then lowering intonation
to my voice and that's just a coping
mechanism I came up with where to avoid
me getting marble mouth and stumbling
over my words I will occasionally slow
down how I'm speaking and speed up and
go back down to avoid myself becoming
too overly excited when talking so yeah
I couldn't find out definitively whether
or not um King George just stood in his
study screen bug bu bu
bu but there's some evidence to suggest
that he did and that's kind of hilarious
moving on overcoming his stutter
corresponded with growing
self-confidence and Assurance the Duke
often flew himself to appearan as he
went about his Royal duties he developed
an interest in industry and the
contributions of Labor to production
Bertie also took a deep interest in the
working class and job conditions the
Press began to call him the industrial
Prince a nickname which took hold when
he served as the president of the
industrial Welfare Society still his
elder brother he remained destined to
become the next king ber remained third
in Lance to the throne after his father
who occupied it and his elder brother
whose unmarried and childless status
meant that the Duke of York was his
air George the fth had five Sons though
the last of his children Prince John
died from complications of epilepsy in
1919 at the age of 13 He also had a
daughter Mary Princess Royal the line of
succession ran through his sons Edward
Albert Prince Henry and Prince George
Henry exhibited Tendencies towards
Affairs shocking the morals and
sensibilities of the day similar to
those of his elder brother Edward Prince
George as well enjoys scandalous Affairs
yet by the mid 1930s all the brothers
were married except for Edward air to
the throne who exhibited little in the
way of urgency regarding his marital
status Edward enjoyed his bachelorhood
as well as race horses and other forms
of gambling his father the king eyed his
sons with thinly veiled disdain and he
grew closer to Bertie during the 1930s
as well as his granddaughter lilbert who
called his majesty and I quote Grandpa
England of Edward he wrote to a friend
after I am dead the boy will ruin
himself within 12 months he also
expressed a hope that Edward would
neither marry nor have children which
would leave Bertie as the heira parent
Edward FAL curious was keenly aware of
his father's opinion towards him and
their relationship grew strained as
Europe marched towards Fascism and War
in the turbulent 1930s in 1934 Edward
began a relationship with Wallace
Simpson an American divorce remarried to
a shipping magnate the married Simpson
and the heir to the throne did little to
conceal their relationship scandalous
though it was when his father George the
demanded an explanation Edward insisted
that relationship was merely a platonic
friendship members of parliament and the
Press Express concern over the
relationship partly due to the moral
outrage at Simpson's marital status and
partly over a status as an American and
its potential influence over the British
throne so yeah just as an idea of how
stuffy and up their ass they were back
then being American was just as bad as
being a married woman and that's thing I
like doing these like scripts on like
kings and English History because you
know my accent does not all suits the uh
the the kind of tone you'd expect for an
article about King George I and w at the
time was already suspected of having
Sympathy for the German Nazi party which
also Drew considerable support from the
German American Bond and other similar
groups in the United States in January
1936 George V died and Edward ascended
to the throne as King Edward VII Bertie
was elevated to the air apparent since
the unmarried King had no issue then
Edward shot the nation by announcing
despite being warned not to his
intention to marry Wally Simpson as soon
as she could be divorc from her husband
his government informed him that he
could not marry his intended and retain
the throne berti still resigning with
his family in the house on Picadilly was
suddenly thrust into a linelight as the
air the public was divided the upper
classes for the most part were unwilling
to accept Edward's choice of bride the
working classes were more supportive the
German Nazi propaganda machine on the
other hand chortled over the class
divide within the British Nation on
December 10th 1936 Edward and his three
surviving Brothers gathered at Fort
beler a Country House in the hands of
the royal family there Edward signed his
letter of abdication after months of
legal and religious maneuvering at the
time of Edward's abdication berti
ascended to the the throne it was a
position he had neither prepared for
wanted and according to much of the
press and gossip at the time was IL
equipped physically and emotionally too
fulfill his daughter Lil but became The
Heir Apparent as the firstborn of the
Monarch Edward had not held the throne
long enough for a formal coronation
ceremony as March 12th 1937 had been
selected for the event Bertie and the
government agreed to let it stand by the
Ty's coronation Bertie had already
bestowed Edward and Wallace Simpson with
their titles the Duke and Dutch of
Windsor he allowed his brothers to adopt
the title of his Royal Highness but
denied it to Simpson and he further
enhanced Edward's finances by purchasing
Bal moral and sanding him from him which
George the fifth state had left to
Edward personally and just the idea that
just the king just owns houses and just
doesn't pay tax on them CU that's like a
thing Bertie had also dealt with his
first major crisis Ireland had responded
to a turmoil in the British government
over Edward's relationship by abolishing
the office of governor general of the
Irish free state and appointee of the
crown it was a major step towards Island
becoming a Republic yet Island was a
little more than a distraction for the
government at the time British politics
and foreign policy in 1937 were largely
dominated by appeasement of the
expansion of Germany on the European
continent George V 6 had no choice but
to support the policy of his prime
minister Neville Chamberlain despite the
growing protest against them led by
Winston Churchill yes that Winston
Churchill when Chamberlain returned to
Britain having obtained the Munich
agreement promising peace in our time
and if you don't know like how like
wrong that was if we've not done a
biographics on Chamberlain that's like
on screen right now ask his in the
comments to do one because yeah he was
like he wasn't wrong he might have been
the most wrong anyone had been that year
he was so wrong anyway the king and his
family asked the prime minister to
appear with them on the balcony at
Bingham Palace the appearance of a
politician alongside the King was a
nearly unprecedented alignment of
monarchy with politics it was also a
clear sign that the king intended to
modernize the monarchy to meet the new
demands of the times in 1939 George took
his intentions one step further
undertaking a tour of North America
which included the United States and
this was the first visiting history of a
reigning monarch to
America president Rosevelt personally
planned much of berties and his wife
Elizabeth brief sixday visit to the
United States in June 1939 he calculated
it to ensure the king and queen received
maximum exposure to cheering crowds as
the Monarch toward Washington DC and New
York City during the Washington phase of
the trip the king visited Mount Vernon
including the tomb of George Washington
a formal State Dinner marked his
Washington visit in New York the Royals
attended the World's Fair after which
they made a less formal visit shall we
say to FDR's home in Hyde Park on the
Hudson River in New York state there FDR
held an informal cookout serving the
king the American dely of hot dogs on
the porch of his mother's house the
king's comments regarding hot dogs were
rather unfortunately not recorded the
FDR Library contains a transcript of
George I 6 handwritten notes made of the
time of his trip the king reported two
good conversations as well as many
opportunities of informal talks between
his majesty and the president these
talks include discussions of the
Neutrality Act including the possibility
of the Americans finding and I quote
something could be done to make it less
difficult for the USA to help us his
majesty recorded several of FDR's
complex plans for Naval Patrol in the
Atlantic in the event of war between
Britain and Germany including the
observation if he saw a hubo he would
Sinker at once and wait for the
consequences when Britain declared war
on Nazi Germany in September 19 39 in
response to the German invasion of
Poland it did so with the monic assured
of aid from the United States as far as
was possible FDR's carefully
orchestrated tour and the king and
queen's gracious acceptance of American
hospitality and policies gave birth to
the so-called special relationship
between the United States and United
Kingdom which has endured ever since
after the War Began and London was being
bombed Georgia's decision to remain in
Bingham Palace rather be relocate to a
safer area resonate with the American
people as it did with the
British
during the blitz on London us newsmen
especially Edward AR Morrow kept the
Americans informed the British
determination to not give in the royal
family demonstrated that resolve by
remaining in London with their standard
flying over bookum Palace in 1940 as
France collapsed Winston Churchill
replaced Chamberlain as prime minister
the king preferred his longtime friend
Lord Halifax but he learned to work with
Churchill nonetheless and they met
weekly over launch at the palace
whenever possible throughout the war the
king and queen remained at Bingham
Palace throughout the Blitz and later V1
V2 attacks sharing the danger with their
subjects the boy once frightened by any
and all loud noises refused to turn to
safety from German bombs exploding
overhead and just as an aside here that
weekly meeting thing is a tradition that
continues to this day and reportedly the
current rainning Monarch meets the Prime
Minister once a week and although um the
queen and now the king um officially do
not endorse any particular political
party and exude no hard political power
they wield a great amount of what is
known as soft power which is just not
necessarily like you know just saber
rattling or anything like that but just
a quiet word from them is usually more
than enough to sway um political opinion
one way or the other and just the idea
that this the Prime Minister has to go
meet the Monarch every week for tea is
just hilarious to me like what a weird
country I live in berti and Elizabeth
made several trips to the front during
the war talking strategies with generals
and foreign leaders and meeting with the
troops to boost Moran while other
governments and royal families of Europe
went into Exile several in Canada George
Elizabeth m maintained a high public
profile a symbol of British resistance
and resolve most of which was faked as
I'll get to in a moment because I've
researched his independently and it's it
kind of sucks but yeah the once
reluctant Monarch used the throne to
strengthen his people and the British
public responded with agulation when the
Germans surrendered in May 1945 huge
crowds gathered outside booking and
Palace demanding to see their King
George shared the Limelight and
accolades with Churchill as he had with
Chamberlain several years earlier just
in regards to that whole like British
resolve thing like stiff upper lip like
if anyone's familiar with the whole like
you know just keep calm and carry on
that was like wartime propaganda for
Britain of like you know stiff up a lit
remain British and much of that was
propaganda both during and after the war
for example there was a very famous
image which we probably can't show I
believe it's own my gety images which is
Annoying It's a part of history but it's
of a milman continuing on his rounds
after the Blitz in London that was
actually like a stage photo op but it's
based on similar though not exactly
accurate story of people going to work
after their places of work were blown to
bits by bombs and it's not so much like
just like the British resolve and
refusal to give up and just stiff up a
liment it's just what else am I going to
do that said there are some remarkable
stories of just the fortitude of the
British population during the time one
of my favorites being that people began
discussing the blitz as if it was the
weather so they refer to German bombs
the same way they would like you know a
dark cloud or a thunderstorm with
Housewives being reported as saying
saying the weather's been a bit blitzy
lately blitzy meaning the Germans been
dropping bombs on them for the past
several weeks throughout the war the
royal family Bertie Elizabeth and their
two young daughters tore the front lines
and home front to boost morale often at
considerable danger to themselves the
princesses Elizabeth and Margaret moved
about several of the houses and palaces
of the royal family between appearances
spending much of the war at Windsor
Castle both served in the auxiliary
Elizabeth the future queen as a driver
and automobile mechanic and both made
morale boosting visits and radio
broadcasts throughout the war on V day
with the permission of the king and
queen they left the palace balcony to
mingle with the crowds I remember we
were terrified at being recognized
Elizabeth would say many years
later in the post-war years it quickly
became evident that Britain could no
longer afford to maintain a global
Empire at the same time Independence
movements erupted around the globe in
1947 British India split into two
independent dominions Pakistan and India
the Emperor of India was removed from
George the 6 with many titles that year
India India became a republic in 1950
and the king of India was removed from
his titles as well they remained the
king of Pakistan in 1948 the British
Mandate of Palestine separated creating
Israel and smaller Arab states as well
as a conflict which has continued to
rage for least 75 years as of its
writing and yeah and as of recording is
still ongoing and the less said about
the better this is neither the time nor
the place let's move on as the British
Empire became the British Commonwealth
George and Elizabeth traveled
extensively the end of the empire did
not sit well with some nor the policies
of some of the emerging dominions racial
segregation quickly came to dominate in
South Africa and when the King tour that
country in 1947 to boost his political
fortunes over Jan smootz the Prime
Minister he was told by local lead to
shake hands with only those presented to
him who were white in 1947 libber
despite some reservations on the part of
her mother announced her engagement to
Philip Mount baton Prince philli of
Greece their wedding on November 20th in
1947 was held in Westminster ABY and
before the wedding George I 6 granted
his son-in-law the title of the Duke of
Edinburgh none of the new Duke's German
relatives were invited nor was the
former King and Elizabeth Uncle the Duke
of Windsor the wedding was to have been
a symbol of British Resurgence and the
recovery from the war years in truth
Elizabeth reportedly needed ration
coupons to obtain her wedding dress a
sign that demonstrated Britain's
recovery was far from
complete throughout his life George I 6
had seldom displayed what we'd call
robust health and during his adult years
he was a heavy smoker of cigarettes he
was seldom without want even during
dinner in the late 1940s the effects of
a lifetime of smoking and the stresses
of the War Began to overtake him he
developed circulatory problems lung
cancer and other related ailments in May
1951 he attended the opening Festival of
Britain a world fair type event which
focused solely on the achievements of
Britain and ran throughout the summer he
then retired for a complete rest that
September his left lung was removed and
his health from that point declined
quite quickly as is want to happen when
her lungs removed you know Elizabeth was
representing the king in Kenya in
February 1952 the king had not seen her
and Philip off at the airport in January
when she was received the word of her
father's death on February 6th he died
of a corner at age 56 his funeral was
held on St George's Chapel Windsor on
February 15th on March 26 1969 his
remains were transferred to the King
George I 6 Memorial Chapel at Windsor
his wife the queen mother and his
daughter Margaret lied beside him and in
2022 Queen Elizabeth II as well as
Prince Philip were interred with them as
well George I 6 ascended to a throne
when it was rocked by Scandal with
public faith in the institution of the
monarchy at his Nadia in a letter to his
brother Edward whose behavior and
decision led to George reluctantly
accepting the throne he wrote that he
had wanted to make it steady again
through the war and in tumultuous events
which followed he served as far more
than just a figurehead he kept informed
of events and circumstances with
politicians field commanders and the
troops he also kept in touch with his
people by the time his daughter became
Queen Elizabeth II British faith in the
monarchy had returned He restored faith
in the monarchy through displays of
personal courage and Devotion to his
family and his people his daughter took
off his man all ser living through seven
decades frequently fraught with Scandal
and indiscretions on the parts of other
members of the royal family maintaining
a quiet dignity and clear personal
courage that's putting it rather lightly
and today his grandson sits in the
throne as King Charles I third facing an
imposing Legacy left upon him by his
mother and his grandfather so I'm just
going to just single out that comment in
the script there about indiscretions and
Scandal and tell everyone at home the
story of prince Andrew so prince Andrew
Al to give his proper title a right bell
end um was Infamous even before his like
most major Scandal for being the
helicopter Prince and he earned that
title by just constantly using the Royal
helicopter to fly everywhere and
anywhere and I think they even referenc
this in the crown where his first
appearance is he just flies in a
helicopter because and he's well known
throughout his life has been one of the
worst Royals to deal with it just like
anytime there's like a royal event and
he would turn up he like I hate dealing
with him he's just such a prick and then
he was engaged in a scandal as noted
where he was supposedly I I should say
allegedly just interacted with someone
involved with Jeffrey Epstein and his
well I'm going to put it diplomatically
not great interview where he tried to
defend himself which apparently every
single one of his Royal advisers told
him not to do um he responded to the uh
the claims that he had been pictured
with one of je Jeffrey Epstein's uh
young lady friends and that she
reportedly just a detail that she
reported that oh I just remember his
like flabby sweaty clammy body against
my own he defended himself against that
claim by saying well that possibly can't
be me I Can't Sweat what do you mean you
can't sweat and it's said I Can't Sweat
I had an overdose of adrenaline during
the Forkland war after being shot at and
I Can't Sweat in an interview where he's
visibly sweating he also claimed that he
could not have been there on the day
that this event was said to have
occurred because I was at a Pizza
Express in woking which is Pizza Express
is just like a crappy Pizza chain and
there's no proof that that ever happened
and for some reason it just never really
went anywhere anyway that's a story for
another day and if you would like to see
us cover that story bug Us in the
comments below with feedback and
suggestions for future videos if we do a
prince Andrew one I am definitely
putting my name forward to read that one
out and I'll tell you what as soon as I
see that one written it's going right to
the top of my recording pile and if not
I'll write it my bloody self I'll tell
that to like you know myed I will write
that myself if you want because that is
a story that needs to be told anyway
while you're down there like subscribe
all that good stuff follow me on social
media follow our author Larry holworth
on social media if you are so inclined
and as always go out there and have the
day you deserve
cheers